so we're pretty familiar with the things
benjamin franklin did later in his life
but let's let's just start with the
beginning where where was he born what
was his childhood like he was born in
boston in 1706 he was the tenth son of a
puritan immigrant and as the tenth son
of a puritan if you've studied the
puritans or your bible you know you're
supposed to be your father's tithe to
the lord uh his father was going to send
him to harvard
in order to study for the ministry this
was way back when he knew that
i've always imagined tithe as you give
ten percent of your income you always
think of ten percent away of your i
guess they consider that part of your
wealth you're trying
well it was uh indeed tithing means
giving away ten percent of your wealth
but if you were the tenth son of a
puritan one of the kids was supposed to
be a minister
and in this case it was old ben franklin
which young ben franklin was supposed to
be the minister but he was
not exactly cut for the cloth
you know one day they were salting away
the provisions for the winter and he
said to his father
why don't i say grace over him now we
get it done with for the entire year we
can you know bless the entire food every
day
and so i think his father realized that
it would be a waste of money to send him
to harvard to study for the ministry so
instead he apprentices him uh makes him
become an apprentice to his brother
james who was a printer he was
apprenticed at age 12 to this older
brother who was a printer
let's see at age 12. and that's
essentially i mean you you go do what
your brother's doing this is your
education i mean back then that was the
way you got educated but in return you
were abundant you were
bound to work from age 12 and you know
usually for i don't know you know seven
eight years at least
uh for an older brother and if you've
ever had an older brother this was not
something benjamin franklin liked after
a few years
he rankled
over authority that was one of the ways
he was very american
and
so he has to decide to teach himself
because he's not going to harvard he's
not in school
his father decided instead to make him
an apprentice to the older brother
and so he teaches himself how to be a
good writer
by pulling down the books from his
brother's print shop and publishing
hal's bookshelf he started off with like
bunions pilgrims progress and uh you
know the essays by plutarch and swift
and
defoe all these things you and i were
reading at age 12. absolutely yeah right
and then he taught himself how to write
he would take the spectator magazine
which was a great magazine in london at
the time written by addison and steele
and it would arrive by you know the post
for to his brother's print shop and
franklin would grab it and he would
write down the arguments that addison
and steele did in their essays and then
he would chop them up with scissors he
would cut them up
and put it in a different order and then
try to rewrite the essays in a better
order than addison and steele are done
there's like a he's by then 14 or 15
years old this is really cool it's like
using khan academy to teach yourself but
you're using the spectator from england
instead
and and so he becomes i mean he actually
does start writing then i guess he but
his brother didn't really want to right
his brother wouldn't publish him as i
said he was an older brother and so even
though he became a tolerable writer
he can't get his stuff printed in the
new england current which is his
brother's newspaper so he has a little
trick
he disguises his handwriting
and he makes up a pseudonym and he
writes under a fake name these wonderful
essays he's 16 what's the name that he
uses silence
do good
these are the silence do good essays and
you're talking about a kid who is age 15
or so
making up this character now silence too
good was a woman now here as i say this
is a boy who's a pretty troublesome kid
ben franklin he hangs around the docks
in boston and gets himself in trouble
all the time and he's always cutting
work at his brother's print shop but he
invents a character who's a widowed
older woman
uh who is dating a minister
and uh living out in the countryside so
pretty much the exact opposite of
himself right and it shows
something so important in education
which is how do you let the imagination
triumph and here's a kid
you know 15 years old who invents this
character silence do good and just does
a pure thing of the uh imagination
she was indeed the opposite of ben
franklin but there are lots of traits
that ben franklin gave her and every
week she would write about them that
sort of made you realize okay it's a bit
like ben franklin because she had this
she wrote once i am a mortal enemy to
arbitrary government in unlimited power
i'm very jealous for my rights and my
liberties in other words she's a very
spunky woman who has an aversion to
tyranny and it was a great description
not only of ben franklin but of the
country that ben franklin was helping to
invent and this is you know just to give
people historical context this is well
before the american revolution and
independence from great britain i mean
we're talking about we're talking about
the early 1700s we're talking about the
period around we're talking about 50 60
years before we
really are going to have a revolution
and break away from england but already
he believes in liberty he believes in an
aversion to tyranny and fighting these
things
and you see it in the way that silence
do good every week she would write an
essay until he finally got
you know found out by his brother he
makes fun of the connection between
church and state in massachusetts
because governor the governor you know
dunster and dudley all these people
they're puritan ministers who are also
the heads of you know the governor and
the heads of the legislature at uh in
massachusetts
and he says of governor dudley he said
anybody who goes from the clergy into
government will take your money in two
different ways they'll do it under the
guise of taxes and then they'll do it
under the guise of uh god you know
asking you for a donation
and so
this little kid pretending to be an
elderly woman is making fun of the
connection between church and state and
massachusetts it's the beginning of a
free press and that's a big deal the
church was fairly powerful
in boston in particular
as you know it was settled by the
puritans and it is a
theocratic colony in other words harvard
university the colony of massachusetts
and the puritan hierarchy were all the
same i mean it was all the same people
cotton mather and increased mather and
governor dudley they were the ministers
they were the people who ran the state
they were the people who ran harvard so
silenced a good i guess we said she's
the opposite she was maybe
demographically the opposite of him but
philosophically right he's using
somebody who's you know totally a
different type an elderly woman to
express his own philosophical ideas so
he doesn't get caught by his brother